il préfère un centre parce que tout à
l'heure
elle m'a dit j'ai peur je suis dans tous
mes états je vais vous expliquer comment
va se passer l'émission je qui compte
sur ma porte apaisé te calmer le 10 km
est une attitude pour te calmer voilà
maintenant si tu concerné madrid
jusqu'au bout avec moi
écoute moi alors j'ai pas dit j'ai pas
dû à celle écrite comme alors que ça y
va pour te protéger la tombe bien parce
que main toutes ces caméras servent la
tap ou bien de citer les spectateurs qui
te désire à tort et à travers
alors j'ai quand même bien qu illusion
je serai là oui tu n'a rien d'un chrono
à 6 il ya quand même des gens qui vous
reprochent à la preuve d'ailleurs il ya
des gens qui me disent c'est vrai que
jonah hill en fait beaucoup
alors